so when Thanos shows up we really wanted  to make this the most powerful moment  ever  eyes up stay sharp the movie sort of  keeps twisting at the end there in ways  that you can't believe that it's going  one step beyond and that the the fate of  our characters and the fate of the  universe are still at play in terms of  our choices about who Thanos would end  up eradicating with his snap you know  it's very story focus how do we pay off  each individual character storyline most  most profoundly Steve the first person  to go is Bucky Barnes and it's shot from  Captain America's perspective you know  we're watching cap go through the  experience of watching him go away we're  watching a Koi a who's number one  mission it is in life is to protect the  king she watches the King go in front of  her and to see those characters react in  those situations is very powerful and  and resonant crude